[MUSIC]
The way memory works is
in terms of snapshots.
I don't remember the entire experience.
I remember moments in that experience.
And why is that so critical because it
tells you that what you need to manage is
not the film, but
it's specific kind of moment.
What people most remembers
is that end overall,
people rate colonoscopies that take
longer but end less painfully,
better then colonoscopies that
are shorter but end more painfully.
It doesn't matter how long something took.
It matters how it ended.
They remember the end, which we've talked
about, but they also remember the peak.
It's something called the Peak & End Rule.
People take those two
pieces of information and
that's how they remember an experience.
You can think of, you go to Disney
you go on the ride, that's an up and
then you wait in line that's a down,
you go from sort of location, or location.
It's not kind of a uniform experience,
it has all kinds of spikes, okay?
And it has kind of moments in which
experiences naturally break up.
So if you think in terms peak and end,
you want to break up an experience when
you're near the top of something, right?
So then when I think back as
a customer about my entire experience
what I've coded in my head
is a series of peak modes.
A lot of companies forget,
the importance of finishing strong.
Hotels, they'll do a lot for
you when you come in, but
then when you check out that
process isn't really managed right?
It would actually be smart and appropriate
for them to give you a departure gift.
So remember any kind of customer
experience that you have,
go back to your desk after this webinar
and ask yourself, how do we finish?
How does this thing end?
>> Understand how consumers experience and
rewire your approach to product strategy.
Learn more about
Innovative Product Leadership,
The Emerging Chief Product Officer.
[MUSIC]